[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hey everybody this is pete snellow here
to give you an irlords podcast first
look at moon glow bay
so i wanted to make sure i took the time
out to show everyone uh moon glow bay
and i will tell you that this game
is not a game i was expecting
to like
from everything that i kind of was
playing and heard about it it was very
slow paced and it was kind of sad and i
was like i don't know if i want to play
this
um but i ended up getting a copy of it
um from uh from bunny hug and i want i
said to myself you know what
let's give it a try let's see how it is
um so
the game
is set in that 8-bit pixelated look
and i will tell you that it is perfect
for this game now the reason why i say
it's perfect for this game is because
it gives the beauty of that old school
feel while giving it
so many new types of options for
instance
you end up um starting this um
this journey i can say uh i don't want
to give out too much of the plot but uh
you end up starting with nothing uh as a
as a fisherman and all you're doing is
having a rod and reel on the side of
your on the side of the um anyway on the
side of the shore uh and then after a
while you know you eventually get to
build uh get money for your
your boat and you get you know all this
other stuff uh where you end up getting
to be able to then you know fish off of
your boat
now
the thing that i really liked about it
is that it gives you a really nice mix
of
uh
fishing while cooking
to allow you to get uh you know a lot of
different types of
um
food or recipes if you can say uh to
make money in the game
and
pretty much revitalized
this
town called moon globe
and
you know
i ended up saying to myself i'm only
going to play for a couple of hours just
to see how it is and i just ended up
playing it and playing it and playing it
and playing it to the point where i was
just like
oh my god i'm like i i have you know
other responsibilities i have to do so i
pull out to pull myself off of it and
then i ended up
uh
you know having to take care of other
things
but the game is really beautifully done
it's very very relaxing
anybody can play it the way that the rod
and reel system works
it's very very simplistic
the way that the um
the cooking is done with the mini games
i loved it i really really think if you
want something to just sit back chill
relax and play
then this is that type of game you go
ahead and play this for you know a
couple of hours and the next thing you
know it's the next day so it is is
something i would definitely uh take the
time to uh you know take a look at
um so once again uh that's moon glow bay
go check it out um this is pete uh again
uh for the honors podcast uh if you're
looking for me my name is sneldo uh and
you can find me on twitch uh every
single day um monday to friday from 3 to
11 uh if you go ahead and check this out
there uh and make sure that you're going
to the uh check out the ireland's
podcast every single sunday and if you
are looking to
uh you know get your everyday news
please go to lords of gaming.net and uh
we can end up getting some more
information there so all right thank you
again and have a great rest of your week
bye everybody
i would play dead by daylight if i owned
it
honest to god i don't own it or i would
[Music]
i'm not friends with you on steam what
is your
here
i'm gonna do this
now you can't tell me we're not friends
on steam
because i would honestly play dead by
daylight that's something i've actually
been wanting to play
[Music]
um
[Music]
do you have d by daylight live
would you want to play together
you would
and potatoes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
no
[Music]
get potatoes
[Music]
you would
uh all right
i will play dead by daylight with you
at nine o'clock
it took an hour
okay okay
okay
[Music]
grant belly fish
cook it
all right wash
get fish
get fish
wash fish
boom
fry fish
boom
okay
we got three more versions of fish
so now
and we'll play dead by daylight at in
one hour
[Music]
oh no we gotta like
go to bed or some crap now right
[Music]
boom
[Music]
that's funny
[Music]
uh
[Music]
excuse me
oh this is kind of fun
oh
there we go
so i guess uh
depending upon
there it is
yeah
i'll ban him in a second
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
no i released them back
[Music]
at least now
[Music]
[Music]
get him in here
that i want to see what happens if i
tried to net them
oh
[Music]
i naturally want to hit that right
button
am i allowed to do that
oh okay that does not work
[Music]
it's like the warcraft uh
was called fishing but way better
[Music]
you